- [Instructor] Before we
get into electron affinity,
let's really quickly
review ionization energy.
And let's start with a
neutral lithium atom,
with an electron configuration
of one s two, two s one.
A lithium atom has three
protons in the nucleus,
so a positive three charge.
Two electrons in the one s orbital,
so here are the two electrons
in the one s orbital,
or our core electrons,
and one electron in a two s orbital.
This is our outermost
electron, our valence electron.
The valence electron is shielded
from the full positive
three charge of the nucleus
by the presence of the core electrons.
So like charges repel,
and these core electrons
repel this outer electron,
and shield it from the
full positive three charge.
But there still is an attractive force
between the positively charged nucleus
and this outermost electron.
So opposite charges attract,
and our outermost electron
still feels a pull from the nucleus.
Therefore, since the outer
electron is attracted
to the nucleus, it takes energy
to completely pull away
this valence electron
from the neutral atom.
So if we pull away the outermost electron,
we lose our valence electron,
and we're left with a lithium
ion, with a positive charge.
Positive one charge, because
we still have three protons,
but only two electrons now,
so overall a plus one charge.
Since this ionization takes
energy to rip away the electron,
the energy, the ionization
energy, is positive,
and is measured in kiloJoules per mol.
Let's compare that with electron affinity.
So, in electron affinity,
let's say we're starting
with our neutral lithium atom again,
but this time, instead of
taking an electron away,
we are adding an electron.
So, we would add an electron
to the two s orbital.
So we started off with three electrons
in the neutral lithium atom,
and we're adding one more.
So the electron configuration
for the lithium ion
would be one s two, two s two.
So still three positive
charges in the nucleus,
two electrons in the one s orbital,
but now we've added an electron,
so we have four electrons total,
two in the two s orbital.
So let me highlight the electron
that we added in magenta.
So this is the electron that we added
to a neutral lithium atom.
And this electron, we know, is shielded
from the full positive
three charge of the nucleus
by our two core electrons in here, right?
So like charges repel.
It's also going to be
repelled a little bit
by this electron, that's
also in the two s orbital.
So this electron's going
to repel this one as well.
But, there is an attractive force
between our positively charged nucleus
and our negative charge on the electron.
So this electron that we added
still feels an attractive
force that's pulling on it
from the nucleus.
And so, if you add this fourth electron,
energy is given off.
And since energy is given
off, this is going to have
a negative value for
the electron affinity.
For adding an electron to
a neutral lithium atom,
it turns out to be -60 kiloJoules per mol.
So energy is released
when an electron is added,
and that is because the
electron that we added
is still able to be attracted
to the charged nucleus.
So if the nucleus has an
attraction for the added electron,
you're going to get a negative value
for the electron affinity.
Or that's one way to
measure electron affinity.
Note that the lithium anion is larger
than the neutral lithium atom.
It's just hard to represent
it here with those diagrams.
So as long as the added electron
feels an attractive
force from the nucleus,
energy is given off.
Let's look at one more comparison
between ionization energy
and electron affinity.
In ionization energy, since
the outer electron here
is attracted to the nucleus,
we have to work hard
to pull that electron away.
It takes energy for us to
rip away that electron.
And since it takes us
energy, we have to do work,
and the energy is positive,
in terms of ionization energy.
But for electron affinity,
since the electron
that we're adding is attracted
to the positive charge of the nucleus,
we don't have to force this,
we don't have to do any work.
Energy is given off in this
process, and that's why
it's a negative value for
the electron affinity.
Electron affinities don't
have to be negative.
For some atoms, there's
actually no attraction
for an extra electron.
Let's take neon, for example.
Neon has an electron configuration
of one s two, two s two, and two p six.
So there's a total of
two plus two plus six,
or 10 electrons, and a positive
10 charge in the nucleus
for a neutral neon atom.
So let's say this is our nucleus here,
with a positive 10 charge, 10 protons.
And then we have our 10 electrons here,
surrounding our nucleus.
So this is our neutral neon atom.
If we try to add an electron,
so here let's add an electron.
So we still have our 10
protons in the nucleus.
We still have our 10 electrons,
which would now be our core electrons.
To add a new electron, this
would be the neon anion here,
so one s two, two s two, two p six.
We've filled the second energy level.
To add an electron, we must
go to a new energy level.
So it would be the third energy level,
it would be an s orbital,
and there would be one
electron in that orbital.
So, here is, let's say
this is the electron
that we just added.
So we have to try to add an
electron to our neon atom.
But if you think about the
effective nuclear charge
that this electron in magenta feels,
alright, so the effective nuclear charge,
that's equal to the atomic
number, or the number of protons,
and from that, you subtract
the number of shielding electrons.
Since we have 10 protons in
the nucleus, this would be 10.
And our shielding electrons
would be 10, as well.
So those 10 electrons
shield this added electron
from the full positive
10 charge of the nucleus.
And for a quick calculation, this tells us
that the effective nuclear charge is zero.
And this is, you know, simplifying things
a little bit, but you can think
about this outer electron
that we tried to add,
of not having any
attraction for the nucleus.
These 10 electrons shield it completely
from the positive 10 charge.
And since there's no
attraction for this electron,
energy is not given off in this process.
Actually, it would take energy
to force an electron onto neon.
So if you wrote something out here,
and if we said, alright,
I'm trying to go from,
I'm trying to add an electron to neon,
to turn it into an anion.
Instead of giving off energy,
this process would take energy.
So we would have to force,
we would have to try
to force this to occur.
So it takes energy to force an electron
on a neutral atom of neon.
And we say that neon has no
affinity for an electron.
So it's unreactive, it's a
noble gas, and this is one way
to explain why noble gases are unreactive.
This anion that we intended
isn't going to stay around for long.
So it takes energy to force
this onto our neutral neon atom.
So you could say that
the electron affinity
is positive here, it takes energy.
But usually, you don't see positive values
for electron affinity, for
this sort of situation.
At least, most textbooks
I've looked at would just say
the electron affinity of neon is zero,
since I believe it is hard to measure
the actual value of this.
Here we have the elements
in the second period
on the periodic table, and let's look
at their electron affinities.
We've already seen that adding an electron
to a neutral atom of lithium
gives off 60 kiloJoules per mol.
Next, we have beryllium, with a zero value
for the electron affinity.
That means it actually takes energy.
So this number is actually positive,
and it takes energy to add an electron
to a neutral atom of beryllium.
So if you think about going
from a neutral atom of beryllium
to form the beryllium anion,
when we look at electron configurations,
neutral atom of beryllium
is one s two, two s two,
and so, to form the negatively
charged beryllium anion,
it would be one s two, two s two,
and to add the extra electron, it must go
into a two p orbital,
which is of higher energy.
And so, this is actually the
same thing, or very similar,
to neon, which we just discussed.
For neon, the electron
configuration was one s two,
two s two, two p six, and
to add an extra electron,
we had to go to the third energy level.
We had to open up a new shell.
And the electron that we
added was effectively screened
from the full nuclear charge
by these other electrons.
And a similar thing happens
here for the beryllium anion.
To add this extra electron,
we have to open up
a higher energy p orbital.
This electron is, on average,
further away from the nucleus,
and is effectively shielded
from the full positive
charge of the nucleus, and
therefore, there's no affinity
for this added electron.
So there's no affinity for this electron,
so it takes energy to
form the beryllium anion.
And that's why we see this
zero value here for beryllium.
Beryllium has no value
for electron affinity,
or, it's actually a very positive value,
and we just say it has a zero value.
Next, let's look at boron here.
So this gives off -27 kiloJoules per mol.
And we can see a little
bit of a trend here,
as we go from boron to
carbon to oxygen to fluorine.
So as we go across the
period on the periodic table,
more energy is given off, and therefore,
fluorine has the most
affinity for an electron.
So as we go across a
period, we get an increase
in the electron affinity.
So the negative sign just
means that energy is given off,
so we're really just
looking at the magnitude.
More energy is given off when you add
an electron to a neutral atom of fluorine,
than if you add an electron
to a neutral atom of oxygen.
And we can explain this general trend
in terms of effective nuclear charge.
As we go across our period,
we also have an increase
in the effective nuclear charge.
And if the added electron
is feeling more of a pull
from the nucleus, which
is what we mean here
by increased effective nuclear charge,
more energy will be given off
when we add that electron.
So this idea explains the general trend
we see for electron affinity,
as you go across a period,
we get an increase in
the electron affinity.
We've already talked about
beryllium as an exception,
neon as an exception, but
what about nitrogen in here?
We can see that nitrogen
doesn't really have
an affinity for an
electron, and you'll see
many different values for this one,
depending on which
textbook you're looking in.
But if we look at some
electron configurations
really quickly, we can
try to explain this.
So, for nitrogen, the
electron configuration
is one s two, two s two,
and then two p three.
So if we draw out our orbitals,
let's just say this is the two s orbital,
and then these are the
three two p orbitals.
So we'll just do these electrons here.
Two electrons in the two s orbital,
and then we have three
electrons in the p orbital.
So let's draw those in there.
If we try to add an electron
to a neutral nitrogen atom,
we're adding an electron
to one of these orbitals,
which already has an electron in it.
So adding an electron to one
of these orbitals, right,
the added electron would be repelled
by the electron that was
in there to start with.
And this is the reason that
you usually see in textbooks
for the fact that this
does not follow the trend.
Nitrogen doesn't have an
affinity for one added electron.
So after going through all of that,
it's obvious that electron affinity
is a little more complicated
than ionization energy.
In ionization energy, we
had a pretty clear trend,
and it was a little easier to explain why.
For electron affinity,
going across a period
on the periodic table, we
see a little bit of a trend,
but there are many exceptions to this,
and perhaps our explanations
are a little bit too simplistic
to explain actually what's going on.
But across a period, you do
see a little bit of a trend.
Going down a group is much harder.
You see more inconsistencies,
and it's not really even worth
going over a general trend for that.